Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number
and that number is 2192. David P.
Last week we talked about Hispanic and Latino
and a caller called in and is very confused
about some different terms, including
a third term, which is Spanish. Now,
I have a lot to say about this one, but let's
first play the voicemail and then we will discuss.
Speaker 5: And David, I was just watching
your show on white Hispanic. The rashes
or whatever are the worst. I'd like to point
out that there is no country named Hispaniola
and. I've known quite a few Spanish folk in my
day and I don't know what the word Hispanic.
Because if you just break it down it is panic.
Mhm. And it's very racist. I never use it. The
term Spanish would be more correct.
Speaker 1: It really wouldn't
actually. Will explain why in a moment.
Speaker 5: You know, there's lots of people who
speak Spanish. They're from the Spanish country.
Speaker 1: What is a there? There's only one
Spanish country and that's Spain. Okay. So this
is where the confusion is. And not to pick on this
guy, a lot of people have this confusion.
I'm going to address it in a moment. But.
A Spanish country, there's only one
Spanish country and it's called Spain.
Speaker 5: You know, you call everybody who's
brown Mexican. That's kind of racist, too.
Anyway. So here you are. Not only putting
it in prayer, but repeatedly saying one word
that shouldn't even exist. It
was created by white people
back in the days of extreme racism. You
know, I. Like I say, a lot of Spanish folk,
they don't like that word. Yeah.
Speaker 1: The guy is using Spanish
folk wrong. He. He's only making this worse.
Speaker 5: It's, you know, it is in just it's
just two words press together.
Speaker 1: His
and panic. It's his panic and it's her panic.
And it's just it's they're panic in Spanish.
Speaker 5: You know? Does that even sound proper?
It's almost like the word, you know, the N-word,
you know, where, you know, it's negative.
Speaker 1: Yeah, it's really not. First of all,
so. So, oh, my boy. How do I even do this? So,
first of all, the way that the word Hispanic
sounds in English is kind of irrelevant
because the same word if Bono exists in
Spanish as well. And it doesn't it it doesn't
mean his or her panic. So like that analysis is
very odd. But here's the bottom line on this.
First of all, when we say Hispanic, well, now
I'm saying it Hispanic. When we say Hispanic,
we're talking about a Spanish speaking person,
usually of Latin American descent. Okay. Now there
are people like this guy who will say what you
mean is Spanish. These are Spanish speaking people
like Spanish people from Mexico and Spanish people
from Chile. But that would be wrong. The only
Spanish people are the people of Spain. There
is one Spanish country and it's called Spain. If
you're from Spain, you're Spanish. If you're from
Mexico, you're Mexican. If you're from Argentina,
you're Argentinean. If you're from Chile,
you're Chilean. So the Spanish thing is neither
here nor there. And this is a big source of
confusion where I've met people who go, oh, you're
you're Spanish. No, I'm Argentinean. In Argentina,
they speak Spanish. I've also had people say
when I say, oh, I'm I'm I'm from Argentina,
they go, oh, I didn't know you were Mexican. I'm
not. I'm from Argentina. Different country. But
the third part of this is the racist origin
of the term Hispanic. Now, there is a lot of
scholarship on this. I can tell you personally,
as someone who is not Spanish, I'm not from Spain,
but I consider myself both Hispanic and Latino.
Either word is fine and my belief is that it is a
correct word to describe me in the United States
based on the census. I'm considered Hispanic
and I am also of Latino origin, Latin American
descent, whatever. But Spanish is very wrong.
I'm definitely not Spanish, so I hope that that
clarified an altogether confusing situation. We
have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: We will talk about the mass stabbing
in Canada, which is being used by a lot of
people for political reasons. We will talk about a
Nirvana lawsuit over the album cover to their 1991
Nevermind album. Very interesting lawsuit. And we
will talk about Rhonda Santos's voter fraud hunt,
which has completely backfired. Sign up at
join Pacman dot com. And if you want to take
advantage of an ungodly membership discount. We
will be emailing everyone on our newsletter list
on 919 about a 19 themed membership special. You
need only get on my mailing list by signing up
at David Pakman dot com sign up there. And then on
the morning of 919, you will get a beautiful email
telling you how to sign up. I will either see you
on the bonus show today or back here tomorrow.